this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to another Sunday now the sunset
Safari here with us in drama in the sabi
sands it is a very nice warm 27 degrees
Celsius 80 degrees Fahrenheit and my
name is indeed Steve Felton bridge and
I'm joined on camera Bisons on keys it
and we're out in the wilderness
searching for all sorts of things
wonderful please same for your questions
or comments hashtag safari live or
follow us on youtube stream we just came
around towards gallagher pad because
while we're doing our checks at camp we
could hear some Franklin's and some go
away birds are having a little bit of a
shouting match and come around to have a
look and there's not much going on but
it's not impossible for Tandy to have
moved all the way from the east to the
side she has done it before I mean James
had a in the week killing in the island
not far from here in the middle of the
afternoon so who knows what could be
happening but maybe it is a bit warm for
her to be moving not too warm for the go
air birds to be frolicking around in the
tree okay I guess very very good it's
feeding on that on other on the seeds it
was very hard to say or on little little
shoots coming off of the plant itself it
is one of their favorite died yes that
go a bit has indeed got the munchies and
they quite enjoy eating the new leaves
that grow off for plants at just that
little sort of sprouts that comes out
and they're also feed on whatever fruit
that might provide and that is indeed at
amber tea tree so interestingly enough
the tambour tea has dropped all of its
leaves and those are all little seeds
that are forming it seems and he is
having a good little munch so but Sam
booty which we think is so inaccessible
to most yet to provide a
a huge amount of sort of forage for all
the animals that come and go and go away
indeed okay since let's move on and down
we go it is a wonderful Sunday and it is
not only me out this afternoon this one
other gentleman on Drive or should I say
on walk wonder if you can guess who I
have a feeling you're gonna be able to
guess quite easily
well send through your questions or
comments this afternoon we'll see what
we can come up with with regards to our
characters for the week and the
gentleman in question is on foot
I'm on foot I'm walking I am walking
towards biffle's Hook water hole in the
Northeast we're hoping there to find
Tandy and her baby - lamba my name is
James Henry in case you didn't know that
the focus is on camera today there he is
marvelous we're strolling along and in
front of us
striding away of course is the great
Hobart de caza birthday boy
he turned 78 years old today if you can
believe it for a 78 year old man he's
moving with a polishing agility all
right as I say our plan is to find Tandy
and it's that please talk to us using a
hash text file at 1:00 today otherwise
you can use the chat room on youtube
we've got some bricks and flap wings
over there that are alarming us very
peaceful Sunday afternoon I always like
to walk on Sunday afternoons as I said
of course that it's meaningless out here
the days of the week but for us it
really is sort of programmed into us I
think from our days at school these sort
of seven-day rhythm and it's very
difficult to let go there and it always
feels like Sunday on Sundays even though
it's the same as every other day and so
I always like to walk on a Sunday
afternoon
makes me feel greatly at peace speech
man you say that I'm very theatrical
well you know if there was one other
thing I could have done with my
existence it would have been to try and
act and make money from the act of
acting in South Africa that's a near
impossibility of course man I don't hold
any other citizenship so well I couldn't
go to Hollywood and try my luck there
you know busking on the streets as a
youngster eventually rising to the
heights of blockbuster movies and living
in a mansion in Beverly Hills
nor could I go to the United Kingdom and
start in Love Actually for example and
become a star there like Hugh Grant I
think he and I are
similar in many ways far the unfortunate
incidents with prostitutes
I had never had any of those thankfully
but being a South African I have had to
basically content myself with this and
well I'm enjoying it very much indeed
all of you wishing happy birthday to
Herbert he's well deserving of a happy
birthday we've sung to him many of us
have summed him today we had a second
song for him today just after breakfast
we put a matchstick in a muffin and sang
to him that was me and Happiness the
chef Alex Alex the Russian saying as
well just marvelous good
all right back to Stevo with a bird yes
well we do have a very beautiful bird a
greater blue eared Starling perch there
nicely on the variable bush willow
branch looks quite dark in some places
but indeed it is a very very blue color
and then it's from the carotenoids in
the feathers there's also a lot of melon
in there which keeps it strong and
protects it from the Sun but at
different angles of light provide that
beautiful blue sheen that you find on
the bird and the greater blue eared you
can see just underneath the eyes a very
sort of dark patch there it's hard to
see on the camera now but the backs got
a little bit of a greenish blue tinge to
it win the Cape glossy Starling is a
uniform blue all over without that very
dark covert underneath the eye very nice
so we're talking about diets of birds
said the day that came up a few times
and these Linda now are indeed very very
beautiful very common the starlings that
the greats of blue eared is not that not
the most common of the starlings we find
in the park but definitely lots of
Starling species around and the diets of
all the starlings are quite sort of
omniverse you know they will even feed
on on rodents someone sent a little
report through I think
dr. ohn Davies sent through a report the
other day off of there some traps they
were trying to catch raptors with with
certain mice sort of baiting stations to
catch themselves to ring them and do
research and on many many occasions they
actually caught starlings coming in so
probably a mainly roadkill then actually
physically hunting down mice and
catching them roadkill or whatever else
might be a bit of a scavenger I suppose
but they have the very nice ability to
be able to walk around on the ground and
competing with the hornbills and the
Franklin's scratching through the
elephant dung looking for all sorts of
insects and also food and a bit of fruit
as well so there's nice adaptations
lying birds to spend the entire year
here and they've got a marvelous call I
really really enjoy the blue you'd call
and a play it for you let's see if he
responds at all I'm wooing him and it's
so bizarre calling back now it's so
bizarre because that death like sort of
squeaky part of the night when I first
came here cuz I haven't spent too much
time with greats blue heads before and I
honestly thought a desert a
white-fronted bee-eater that I heard
because I'm gonna play you their call
there's a betta has got that very sort
of what would you say halloumi cheese
sort of stuck in the beak sort of noise
I'm gonna play it for you and tell me if
you agree with me or not
but the first time I I heard this guy I
thought it was him and James like no
that's a starling like I really here we
go
very similar very similar sort of sort
of sound but the warbles there's a lot
of warbling sounds that come in as off
the Starling and the beaters you know
that gennaker and quite perennial sort
of rivers where there's lots of banks
and they live in colonies I don't know
if you've ever seen one before on the
show but I think I have seen one once
before we can never quickly look at him
over here I've got a nice picture I put
very very beautiful bee-eater hmm
sorry there's not the best picture here
oh it's a little bit of glare
let me there we go oh is that white
fronted beat it cuz it's got white on
the forehead isn't that strange very
very pretty I do I do need to give my
screen and whap I'm terribly sorry I'll
give them my screen Iraq immediately
James you won't know if the feathers are
going to fade I don't think so it's not
actually that they're not gonna fade the
color is actually carotenoids within
this is actually not a color that's a
pigment with inside the feather that is
shining and reflecting the light but I
think as they maybe start getting older
they lose the feathers and they replace
them again so whenever you look at them
in light that just looked different I
don't think it's got too much to do with
nutrients the birds that I'm thinking of
that lose color and pigments is that
derocker's and when they lack a bit of
iron in their diet from the fruits that
they get they lose that red that red
pigment the turret Orson and I know that
because a friend of mine rehabilitates
it and eyes that Sirocco down in the
Cape and obviously it was was injured
was injured for some reason and he was
feeding it at home and rehabilitating
and and obviously lacked the the
nutrients or the the food was getting
from the forest namely the the yellow
wood trees with the fruits and a
completely lost that red pigment and as
soon as he went on to collect to those
fruits that came back again so yes I'm
sure there's a lot of that in in nature
with regards to the pigment so but I'm
not
I've never seen a glossy styling losing
their pigment they just kind of lose a
few feathers and even those feathers
stay very very iridescent after their
being shed but possible there's a slight
change okay well my screen is now
officially nice and clean there's a
gentleman please let us know how you're
doing this afternoon there we go look
how beautiful he is now when he turns
around send through your comments and
questions hash tags fiery lab whatever
whatever stream you prefer having a very
nice go isn't he that very orange eye
helps you to distinguish him from the
virtual Starling a virtuous Starling has
got a black eye he's quite a darker sort
of blue and also very long tail get down
on the floor into the thickets what is
he feeding on anyway are we going to
move on who knows what we will find
around the next corner we're going to be
coming around the corner towards would
tell a watering hole
James Richards bird species with the
most limited diet very interesting I
mean cuckoos seem to feed exclusively on
caterpillars and they're migratory so
there seems to just feed on on the breed
and caterpillars that come it's really a
good question I think any bird that has
to stick around here for our winter
months has to have a varied diet you
have to be varied if you're going to be
able to scratch out there's some Impala
if you're gonna be able to scratch out a
living out here during our winter months
you're going to have to be able to
change your diet so all the Franklin's
and hornbills all these birds have got
quite a mixture of diet but cuckoos
almost feed exclusively on caterpillars
so I would assume that they probably are
quite sort of non varied and then be
eaters also they feed especially that
the European would be coming here for
sort of flying migi like insects so that
could be probably be quite limited but
then again I've never really taken any
sort of investigation into the the tummy
consistency of a lot of these birds
there's something to look at - James
thank you for a very very
thought-provoking question we're talking
about very diets the impala are able to
yeah well the impala got the very diets
and they're able to mix their feeding
from from grazing to browsing as the
need arises and Emma was just making a
comment that oxpeckers have a varied
diet that's a very good point oxpeckers
probably do have a very varied diet
seeing as they feed primarily on ticks
but they'll also feed on flies and and
things that are shuffled away by by
animals as their move is at 100 percent
on on ticks but then there's also a
number of different expand then also
woodpeckers would be feeding
specifically on grubs so yeah I think
it's and they're adapted to be here and
to access things others corn so yeah
very thought-provoking questions thank
you keep them coming let's get some
really nice discussions maybe James
Hendry has an answer to that question
I've no doubt he has got a discussion to
add to who think sense I'm sure he does
well in parlor or looking very relaxed
yeah so I don't think we're going to be
coming across a leopard any moment soon
that someone you will be seeing in next
moment is James himself that's quite
clever to say I don't think we're going
to be coming across a lip at anytime
soon which is to just kind of throw it
out there that you might want to see a
letter but you're not that focused on it
that's when you're likely to see one of
course we're just wandering along we had
some lovely hornbills sitting on top of
the stree but unfortunately they have
flown offs and I'm going to find
something else talk about so glorious
glorious afternoon 27 degrees Celsius
can you believe it this is around 80
degrees Fahrenheit James not really you
know local tradition doesn't celebrate
birthdays now tell you how I know that I
mean we can ask her be there might be
some newer ones but a lot of people
don't actually even know when their
birthdays on if you say how old do you
they'll say I'm 1976 which means I was
born in 1976 obviously and you say what
date nice hour I'm not sure winter or
summer somewhere like that and only much
later when kind of European influences
come into these areas of birthdays
become actually a big thing so they
aren't you know if you think back 200
years there was no calendar people just
lived according to the seasons wasn't
completely random but they lived
according to the seasons and so that
meant that there were no traditional
birthdays because nobody knew actually
when you were born
and I think even the concept of a year I
mean everybody knew what a year was but
it wasn't defined like it is for example
in European culture so there are no
specific traditions
let's just look under here you can
almost always find something underneath
elephant dung we'll just be careful I
used to just kick the stuff over now
we're going to lift it carefully and
make sure that we put it back there's a
latke oh we got another invasion but I
will major invasion going on here
everybody I don't like these scenes and
make me feel very sad look on there
Fergus we've got a raiding party of ants
absolutely obliterating a small colony
of harvester termites emesis and just
makes her feel very itchy but I'm not
surprised about that I dislike these
little scenes and it's because I've
never ever seen the termites fight back
I've never seen them win and makes me
wonder what on earth the point of a
soldier termite is when the ants are
able to come in like this totally
overwhelm the termites destroy them
carry them off take their babies and
it's really horrible I mean if you think
about how awful it is to watch something
like a buffalo dying who's to say that
this termite isn't just as distressed
being swarmed upon by these ants
surrounding them sitting in their burrow
quietly on Sunday afternoon you do well
I mean they'd probably be working as
always but every peaceful and then
suddenly these little red ants come in
they probably just see one Scout come in
stick his head into the into the termite
nest and then they know the rest of them
are coming there's nothing they can do
about it look how the weight of numbers
is entirely on this on the side of the
answer yeah Leslie as it is alive kill
but it's I don't like this live kill
that makes me feel sad I like termites I
have a great affection for them for some
reason
from these answer destroying that piece
that is their want of course why
shouldn't they
that's how they live I don't know if the
termites under the ground actually
managed to sort of see a law for piece
of the nest away from the ants they may
well and that maybe it's just the
surface view that gets smacked I'm alike
of the ants are crawling on me as we
speak they don't bite yet they're not
biting me it I'll pick a few up and I'll
let you know if they're bite though
there are on my hand these chaps I don't
think of biters they've actually got one
devouring termites there one termite
being devoured so far no biting
sensation from the auntie's I wouldn't
do this to a nest of Seattle which of
those East African Safari ants that
wander through our camp and the Mara
from time to time
the last place of attack was Jamie and
Brent's tent it's 2:00 a.m. I think
about three evenings ago listening Leo
Smith vocabulary when the first ant bit
him he was fast asleep it wouldn't have
been pretty anyway that's cheered me up
slightly on the back end of a rather sad
scene here
well why don't I put my ear down here
trends and see if I can hear
yeah they didn't make a bit of a noise
there there little girl ants at least
little girl termites no James I don't
think they have the mechanism for making
noise other than that sound they make
that's the soldiers making that sound
when you destroy threatening to disturb
them but that's their heads bashing
against the side of their tunnels the
amount of activity there of course is
probably directly proportional to the
heat that we find ourselves in in this
mid winter day and my Safari you can eat
just about any termites as far as I'm
aware a hugely important part of the
protein in the diet of people who live
in this area certainly used to be these
termites I don't think of the fungus
growers though I think that they are
actually sure what they are I mean there
could be a danto termes which are fungus
growing but they don't build the man so
they're not the mound growing termites
and I say that because there's no mound
around here they could also be dry wood
termites I'm not actually sure exactly
which species they are but there would
be edible
the fungus growers are much larger than
this generally which means that they are
obviously you have to collect fewer to
make yourself a meal very delicious
apparently cooked with a little bit of
oil and butter or just butter salt and
pepper chilies they taste them like salt
pepper and chilies
everything of course has got to eat out
here and Ally that's what's going on
here
the ants just eat termites they're
predatory ants they eat termites that's
what they do and so that's why they're
attacking them it's exactly the same as
a very large pride of a million Lions
attacking a large herd of 100,000 valle
de vista
now that answer definitely Carnivale you
get ants that are carnivores and
omnivores and vegetarians termites
however karnak are entirely vegetarian
they don't eat anything else they only
eat vegetables they eat dry wood they
eat sometimes living wood they eat the
walls of homes sometimes and they're
largely wood eaters they do sometimes
harvest green leaves arthas's of
termites will take green leaves from
time to time they're the ones that are
yet sort of large black color and they
don't build mounds but none of them eat
meat as far as I'm aware all right let's
put this back and sadly but this poor
termite colony adieu and try not to feel
too resentful to the ants let's go back
to Steve
well we have found something in the road
it looks like very fresh leopard sketch
I was just asking her be because they've
just walked past here and you see this
yes actually not as fresh as I thought
it was you see the pinch me get a stick
not going to touch it I'm going to touch
it see there's a there's a pinch over
yet no it's not that fresh actually you
see that pinch right at the top and at
the bottom very characteristic off of
leopard and also the size you wouldn't
say this is a lion there's lots of fur
inside of there there's even a little
bit of grass I've had to break it open
no doubt I probably find a lot of fun
maybe a bone or two I thought that was
fresh and then it is anyway doesn't have
a smell anymore the good thing even
though I stuck my nose quite close it
doesn't smell well
when we go get around this way
well hello everybody happy Canada Day to
everybody out there I didn't know it was
Canada a happy happy happy Canada Day
what is the dates of this the first of
July very good
I was not aware of that were you sends
oh here we go oh it's a virtual Starling
we're talking about him before is he
going to land no he's not going to land
so we're driving along what's called
Garry Cutler now you might notice on the
left and the right that the grass has
been we've been been dealt with and
that's to prevent fire they're basically
mowed a chair to provide a fire break
without having to put in a fire they've
done a lot of work in the past to prove
that actually mowing grass sometimes
actually works so they put in a little
bit of mowing because it actually
stimulates the grass rather than the
inter burn and burning takes a lot more
people and manpower and can get out of
control so pretty much you think we
should be let me labeled The Chronicles
of poo well indeed indeed I think we
should as well
we do like to talk about it there's a
lot of it around I'm sure that you saw
my book earlier didn't you phew man just
gets a log if you didn't well here it is
it's catalogue thanks very clever
my mom got it for me for my 30th
birthday and she rates in the cover I
have a very something birthday present
neither sassette was a it was a bad word
which kind of robbed with scatter log I
didn't even think it was a birthday
present I think it was a Christmas
present let me read it again yeah there
was a Christmas present
yeah five long time ago come in very
handy
it's even got a ruler you could even
measure all the things on the back in
case you want to know how big the the
circuit is because there's not enough
just to look at it you're going to
measure it and put your book next to it
break it open with a stick to see what's
inside
yeah if you if you want to identify the
difference between certain animals you
got to look for the differences inside
there could be insects if there's if
there's crabs inside that it could be a
water mongoose if there's not then
that's probably not a water mongoose and
if there's a freshwater mussels inside
it could be a fresh it could be a toxic
a porous otter so these things are
important you need a stick you need a
ruler
costas well scatters is quite easy to
identify with regards to lion and
leopard the leopard is as I just showed
you got that very characteristic pinch
at the end and it's a lot smaller than
lion lion can be very similar to leopard
but Lions are much bigger in size but to
identify the difference between a
leopard and a cheetah is is very
difficult actually let's have a look
shall we sing as we honor your topic
the cheetah let's see what it says in
here about a cheetah okay here we go
I don't know if you can see here we got
the leopard on the bottom he has that
characteristic pinch I was talking about
notes this sign that says containing
quills because sometimes they eat
porcupine and then on this side of the
cheetah I don't know I wouldn't know how
to identify a cheetah if I saw it I mean
it's very will be very similar to
leopard but it doesn't seem to have this
characteristic pinch over here but we
don't have as many cheater in the area
than we do as as we do leopard and here
is the lion a lot bigger in size this is
obviously not to scale
there's rulers here that are showing
centimeters so this is far bigger this
is lion
scats about this big and they're really
really big lots of fur and often lots
and lots of bone so sketch quite easy in
that regard
wild cat which is at the bottom here
first of all they like to bury their
their dung so what I've done before
you've probably seen me many times they
sketch sorry
I dig in the ground and I find things
and once I thought I found an aardvark
digging I was very excited I could open
it with my hand and I came out with wild
cats cat in my hand it was fun it was
really fun it was really fun it was like
in between the fingers like oh no what
did I do
well you know and you and we just
started the walk and you're like so that
wasn't fun so I now approach digging
down a little bit differently
we do have caracal in the area here's
the caracal down here it's a lot smaller
the scat here it's a lot smaller but you
know caracal and leopard it would be
quite difficult to idea
to fire early I think would have mainly
be a size comparison but all cats cat is
very very similar in that sort of
appearance but I think size is
everything you got to go for so ideally
what you're looking for when you find
scat is if it's fresh look for some
tracks you know like who did it quite
often you might find some footprints
nearby if it's a little bit old it's
hard it's hard to see and so I hope that
answers your thing it's a never-ending
process
whoo-hoo scat that you know who scat
that or who done that who done that who
dang it indeed the best way to learn
though indeed the best way to learn
Katherine were you not on this morning I
think Taylor got one this morning
Taylor got an African Wildcat in like
the first five minutes I was like what
yeah she got one but the best way to
identify Scouts is to watch an animal
and do it and then go out there and take
your photographs you know for a fact it
was that animal that's the best way to
do tracks help tracks are very helpful
and servo I do quite similar to caracal
except they're known to bury it but not
all the time
so scratch marks bury the done
so
like for example who done that it's
quite easy to see you've done that quite
dark it's in a midden formation it's
large if I broke it open you'd be able
to see there's grass inside it's black
in color it's very fresh
there's scrapings as a midden guaranteed
because it's in a midden and it's dark
like this you could say it's a white
Iran Oh hippo would be similar they
don't use a midden so these are things
that you come getting you stup and
unlike elephant dang which you burned
for good luck and for medicinal value
that's a very taboo to burn white rhino
dung very very taboo indeed so on that
note let's go over to James and see
exactly what he's getting up to
we've got a student book that seems to
be particularly clueless I don't think
she's seen us which is a bit odd because
we've been standing in plain view for
some time still see effort just move
slightly back down the road there she's
going she's gonna move up now just to
the right of that bush it's quite
special to have the steel walk on foot
normally they just run away let's move
this way foot Fergus Potter devices
instead I was trying to break the stick
now I think she's gone to ground it's
quickly get in here there she's just
moving to the left now she seen us he's
here just you got her quick glimpsed she
is looking at us I'm gonna move forward
you just stay where you are
she'll probably move a little bit less
years she's very calm very calm
come come over here food thinking about
running still feeding there she's issues
with it back to us you got it come over
here
you'll get a good view of her this is
just between these two branches yep
now she's disappeared behind the bush
did you get her a glimpse again we'll
try one more view
now most antelope of course are very
seasonal breeders and what are the
Steinbach is no different actually they
are seasonal breeders there will be a
breeding peak there we go
she goes yeah he'll be a breeding peak
in the rainy season
I don't suppose it'll be impossible for
her to have a baby now but it'd be
unlikely there are concentrated feeders
who call concentrate feeders which means
they're gonna need to eat seeds and
bulbs and that sort of thing new
nutritious shoots which would be far
more in abundance during the summer
months did you get a shot there sort of
all right well she's disappeared now I'm
not going to try and follow up there
I picked this particular stick over here
to show you the inside of it and it is a
groovier fluorescence or they call
sandpaper raisin and I broke it because
it's quite an efficient way to make wood
it's very porous and so it's got sort of
a I mean I imagine that these I imagine
the cambium layer probably survives
beyond one year which most trees doesn't
and you can see it's almost like a
sponge and I suspect that this plant is
able to suck up water very effectively
in dry times and also not expend too
much energy on the sort of wood
production side of things and so I
suspect it's a very energy-efficient
plant it has to use little energy to
become sort of scraggly bushed as it
does become so that is the sandpaper
raisin most wood of course is not
anything like a spongy as this was that
not fascinating figures is that the most
fascinating sundae fact you've ever
heard yep it was us what I thought good
excellent
okay don't pick up my proper stick which
is made of Redbush willow oh this is
quite a nice example here of the
difference between spines and forms now
this is of course gymnast aporia Buxa
folia and all of these thorns here will
eventually become branches can you see
there have nodes on them there's a
little node there and that defines them
as spines and not thorns so that
eventually will become branches and it
means that the plant doesn't waste
energy growing just plain thorns for
defence the thorns will eventually
become branches which will eventually
contribute to the actual growth of the
plant so that's the difference between
spine and thorn that's gymnast Poirier
bucks if there live Jackie the biggest
dwarf antelope that we get here is the
duiker so the smallest one is the
Steinbach we don't get doctor care but
duck stick are much smaller than those
the smallest antelope I think we get in
Africa is the blue duiker which is
actually found on in the Eastern Cape
where my parents live and in fact I've
seen one on the golf course and as I've
said to you before when you spend as
much time looking through the forest for
a ball as you as I do well you get to
see quite a lot of good wildlife when
you're on the golf course there and I've
sold seen a little blue duiker I've seen
a blue darken lamb of this big being
hunted by a mongoose being hunted by a
grey Mongoose and just off the air the
13th it you know thee well for tabletop
there yes
Fergus hits the ball a lot straighter
than I do so he hasn't seen Lambs of
blue the blue darker being hunted by
gray Mongoose quite amazing to see an
antelope hunted via Mongoose
yes I think it is quite cool Thank You
Emma let's continue we're heading
marching gently along Central Road the
78 year old birthday boy waiting
patiently for us we're still hoping to
find some tracks of tan dye we have to
be back in camp by quarter past five
because it will be dark alright we're
going to continue our march are you
ready
you increase our speed and as we
increase our speed let us go back over
just Steven thanks James but if we got
sins Oh indeed
hey water back little family of water
back they were just busy relaxing in the
shade doing a bit of a rumination it's
about three females there with a really
big male yes he's sitting down and they
are talking about diets they are hundred
percent grazers feeding on a very bulk
amount of grass they need enormous
amounts of water that you could see the
male he's very relaxing I wouldn't say
that this sort of quite thick bush areas
their ideal habitat
and you find them more often than not
and sort of open clearings jason-2
watering holes mmm Eugene um you want to
know about Parma banana trees no banana
trees but in the Kruger we do get
there's at least two types of palm that
I can think of or three to three there's
the lollipops you get right up in the
north there might occur elsewhere you'll
see at the wild date-palm all over the
place and then I think you must also get
the raffia palm it might be more I can't
think of it there's a number of palm
trees and they all very well utilize for
basket weaving in all sorts of holding
capacity stuff but the lollipop which
goes right up in the north in an area at
might occur elsewhere but I know quite
well in the northern Kruger and Lala in
the local dialect means to sleep so in
the lollipop because it grows tall like
this I don't have a book for it now I'm
sorry big tall palm grows up and then
the leaves come out and if you go up and
you cut those branches where they're
growing out this isn't set looses that
you can collect that set and you can
make la la' wine a lot of palm wine it
is very strong and afterwards you just
just wanna sleep it's not very tasty but
it's it was well renowned for the
Tsongas back in the day by having as
many la la la la land exactly it's
basically they they gauge their
territorial area about how many la la'
palms are had in the area because they
needed to make enough beer or wine per
season per sort of community so there
lots of them up there and unfortunately
some of them have been over harvested
but there are still plenty around
because that a fortune if you cut all
the leaves off quite often the trees die
so from a sustainability point of view
don't even wanna cut off like maybe two
of the branch this witness to lift its
going to grow back but it seeps out this
liquid and you can catch that but palms
all part of the grass family but very
tall beautiful palms indeed and that
they are actually home to a number of
Swift species especially the palm Swift
which we find up there that apparently
never ever touches the ground in its
entire life
palm Swift
constantly flying apparent they even
sleep on the fly not like is water buck
is water buck is that saw something dart
across the road there I'm gonna go over
to look something flashed across the
road there we move on from this water
buck let's just go and see something
white flashed across the road over there
and my dog might have been that horn
ball a hornbill just landed I just got a
flash of white Emmett could have been a
Matt is talking to me on the radio and
it could very well have been a very fast
polar bear but it's unlikely Emma well
it's very unlikely I think it was more
likely a more likely that horn below
thee there it is just on the side a
little bit of a feeding party there's a
red build horn ball also known as the
flying banana off you guys he obviously
did not sign the disclaimer to be shown
on camera so he didn't want to be said
no and off he went
he's very famous bird that one his agent
didn't agree with us putting him on
camera so off he went
actors are indeed very temperamental so
James said he was supposed to be an
actor is any jason stathom stunt double
does jason stathom need a stunt double
I don't think so I don't think so hey
since a you know Jason Statham is Senza
doesn't know Jason Statham is folks that
sends us ask me does Jason Statham who
sends own keys is and I said he probably
doesn't sends but I'm sure we could
maybe make the introduction okay so
talking about scatter gain and don't run
away
wait we had a Nutella spare file that
was quite enjoying digging in there I
know scat well there are no midden which
is down we made up of grass but they're
looking for any grass seeds or you can
see some fresh he's just disappeared in
the background you can see a little bit
of sort of fresher dung in the front in
the middle there there he gums he's not
so shy very orange legs an orange beak
hello Millie 8 years old you'd like to
know which animal dung smells the least
well and we're gonna have to give that
some serious thought
definitely not elephant not Rhino
definitely not any of the Predators I
can tell you that in baboon I can tell
you categorically is probably one of the
worst smelling ones hmm it will probably
have to be one of the herbivores Impala
or not all the best calm people the best
we'd have to think about that you've
given me a very nice question very very
nice question hmm I don't know they all
got a smell to them I suppose they're
caught none of them maybe I don't know
if what it took cEPAL would would do it
what would the people ask Emma what did
they vote for
okay so a question okay I don't know
exactly how I took the question yeah
just a question
hello Scuba Steve we're gonna come and
say hello to you now while we get ready
to frame Scuba Steve will put a question
out there to all of your viewers seeing
as I'm the one who's generally smelling
the done what do you think is the least
smelly animal dung out here go with your
answers three two one go scuba their fee
not scoopers dung any animal that lays
their dung down to be able to find a
trail back is definitely not giving off
an odorless pile of dung are there sins
no well Scuba Steve also didn't sign his
disclaimer he's signed one for last week
but not for this week that's a pity oh
wow well everyone so far
okay well James has got a bird while we
wait for some more answers to come in
very very special bird a green winged
pie Tilia used to be known as the Melba
Finch infinitely better name than green
winged pie Tilia but there it goes that
was the male beautiful red you saw on
his face probably earns chest and on his
tail slightly greenish wings stripey
chest an apparently that is two Volvos
favorite bird then we've got oh that a
brew brew you see the white and black
one there Ferg just jumping to the left
of the main stem of that Susie fools run
in there near the top now on the top
horizontal branch yeah that is the blue
broom so named for the coal that it
makes the telephone bird something like
that anyway it doesn't do the nokia
ringtone
see it ran away as soon as I made the
Nokia turn I know we can't say brands
but you know it's our ego
Herbert just decided that it is now time
to move on the bird party is over let us
continue pointed forward like that and
said raspy Rolf single minded is our
Herbie on his birthday he wants a
birthday leopard yes yes indeed Emma
maybe Columba will jump out of the
birthday hat and perhaps a decent cake
and likely stale muffin that Ari
produced for her but this morning with a
matchstick in it for his birthday so I
thought that fergus I should have been
more aware of the Sun you see how Fergus
moved to be with the Sun they're very
important in summer look at this little
thicket here I'm pretty sure there'll be
something of interest other than wealthy
Rhea indica there are some lichens of
course which are quite fun there are the
lichens the ultimate example of a
symbiosis or a mutualism if you like
mutualism where by a fungus has combined
with an algae to provide an entirely
different kingdom of creatures I'll you
look at that lichen well no you want to
know if I can find a listeria I mean I
see one I'll absolutely be able to tell
you about it a wolf theory er oh well
theory is very easy here we go here is
wealthy ria indica the plant that never
stops giving it almost always find
something eating on wall FIRREA be it a
spider or caterpillar here is something
actually here is there something feeding
on the swarthy area plant I think it's a
leaf hopper of some sort you see it
there just in the Sun how fascinating is
that it's not a leaf hopper it might be
it might looks like a kick beetle it's a
very tiny chick beetle if it is a click
beetle
it is Stephanie a beetle it's too small
for me to tell whether it's a click
beetle or not a click beetle has a sort
of interesting adaptation on the thorax
that allow that it's about two sort of
protrusions that it sticks under two
interlocking gaps if you like on the
abdomen and when he moves them apart
they get thick fascinating
we'd only be able to know if he was a
click beetle if we catched him and he
started clicking here he goes this is on
wealthy Rhea you still see in there
how fun if you know it sit down there he
is no no there he's jumped off now so I
call wealthy Rhea indica the plant that
never stops giving because you can
always always find something giving may
have you found something else vote no
you're just showing us wealthy Rhea
indicate the plant that never stops
giving well done you won't just be able
to hear the fact that the day but for an
alarm calling rattling so stickler is
almost entirely entirely silent
Marcia there is one bulb out here I'd
forgotten its name that can be used for
water but we don't have things like this
tama melons or the few other obvious
ones that you can get in the Kalahari
Desert for example that you can cut and
squeeze and drink the water from but
there are very few roots out here that
you can do it from there's a lot of the
tubers and roots here are very toxic and
I know that Steph has demonstrated
drinking from one of the roots here and
I'm gonna ask her but what it was he's
walked off for the moment but I will ask
him Marcia I've forgotten its name
alrighty so that was wealth area indica
the plant that never stops giving we're
gonna keep looking for the bulb and the
tracks after our lumber and candy Stevo
waits for you
mm well here we have one of the new
Arliss is a family just crossed in front
of us she's decided she doesn't want to
go that way she's going back again
your parlor a reading past for some
reason we have our buffer suck the
watering hole we left Scuba Steve
because he was really not playing in the
game with us he stayed underwater for as
long as he possibly could so a lot of
you viewers are saying that the dung
that probably smells the least is the
scrub hair done with 10 folks you're
talking about the second time it's been
eaten I know what it smells like before
probably smells a little bit got a
little bit of a smell yeah but yeah
you're out scope it but I've got a quiz
who done that ah
don't don't it's into your questions on
hashtag Safari live
hmm and Polly's got a bit of a smell but
Timothy they do I'd say probably quite
quite little in the smell Timothy are we
gonna keep going on maybe I'll find
there we go there's some Impala right
there
Impala scatter out there sir so we did
the test termites Malak oh well that's a
very good answer
too much the dung is just like I suppose
it's just like soil isn't it well we
found some scrub here dung and some
Impala let's see
maybe I needed break it open
their fingers smell I wouldn't say it's
pungent though and this scrub here let's
melt the it's similar very similar
indeed
here we go since they've got a very I
think I need to find some really fresh
and pilot Dan very very fresh and then
we'll get a proper prop a little sniff
of them so I'm gonna leave this on the
dashboard for a while and see if anyone
can figure out who done that possibly a
bit of a trick question
joy it knows definite wildebeest of all
the BS done
I'll try find you some small little
smallish black pellets
cosider Urich an elephant a unicorn well
definite unicorn definitely not a
unicorn but indeed it could be elephant
and I thought I was going to trick you
all a little bit there but it is a baby
elephant young elephant there you can
see the little oh it's going on impalas
are shouting here we go it's still quite
moist inside definitely got to smelt it
let's have a little look hmm
yeah if you got a smell but if we break
it open let's just do it on the outside
break it up and you can see that this is
a full leaf over there there's some
grass some sticks more leaves I mean
that's an it's highly if hasn't even
been chewed nothing's happened to that
leaf nothing at all imagine something
going through your digestive system and
coming out without any damage yes it was
a good baby elephant yet all his veggies
he has some bark or a stick so it just
goes to show how poorly digested these
elephant dung is and there's some very
nice grass okay so indeed indeed it was
elephant and we're going to put it back
on the ground so that the termites can
break it open or turn it back in back
into soil let's just put you over there
nice and piled up we go I think a clear
kid my Silas is up with that
dung in the nose marvellous you should
all try it
yes bronec I think that would be awesome
if we were able to broadcast the smells
as well to all of you to make your cur
just lean a bit closer
smell smell that we could just put
things over here you could choose to do
it or not it wouldn't be like air your
room is going to send you fill up with
the smell of lion poo you know or or
rotting wildebeest carcass or something
you know you could you can choose to be
like put the smell on off I suppose just
like a volume control increase the
amounts of odor decrease it hey we got
something here I think we got something
don't you think sense says I think so
maybe quite interesting and how many of
you would be like I'd be like all the
smells terrible and no don't then you
all have to you sensible heat put your
noses forward you would that's what we
do it's what we do as humans we have to
taste it we we can't help ourselves we
can't help ourselves by smelling bad
smells
child of the universe you would like to
know which dung is the most edible well
hey what's that and where this is the
tracks of tündi this morning is it sandy
and Columba the tracks that is I wonder
where exactly they looks quite fresh to
me yeah I don't know if you can get
these hair sins
that'll be close ice on top of vehicle
tracks from this morning
let her be no I don't know if anyone
follow these because these are on top of
the vehicle tracks you can see the
vehicle is here there's the track
vehicle is here there's the track it's
on top here's two lumbers little track
over here
very cute thing in this direction quite
fresh it was running this track I don't
know if you can see this one here since
can you see it we remember ladies and
gentlemen I was talking okay you
remember I was talking to yesterday
about running tracks while I'm get back
to very Herbie needs me to quickly chat
to him on the radio maybe they found
something but I think he needs to come
and check these art
okay okay while I get hold of Herbie
let's go back over to James
Herbie Herbie Steve Rajeev
that's exciting Steve's got the tracks
he's just over there at the waterhole
you might just be able to hear him
talking to her bit on the radio now so
with any luck we'll homed in on the
kitty cats fairly soon and come over
here Fergus burgers coming coming
yeah
what we have here is a hole obviously
it's not a particularly original thing
say there's a hole and it's a very old
hole I think whoa I say that it's very
deep what created it is most likely a
speaks hinge backed tortoise and you can
see that from the shape of the hole
that's the kind of hole that they dig
and they'll go in there and east of
eight for the winter time in there and
eventually back out during the summer
now if it collapses I think they're
probably able to dig themselves out but
that's the first time I've actually ever
put something into one see how deep it
is let's put something slightly less
offensive than a big stick see how far
in it goes okay that one hasn't reached
the back let's get something a little
bit longer here we go this way or worse
if there is a tortoise in the older will
feel as a little spike in the bottom of
course they're very angry
Merson beacon spitting cobra could come
out it's still going it's quite a lot of
heat coming out of it yes
okay let's see if we can find one longer
thing here we go here's a slightly
smaller stick but firmer as well so
nervous it's bending well if it's
actually reached the end they'll put in
very gently I don't notice pike Ianto
toys on the backside while they're
having their winter snooze
look how deep it is we're still not at
the end now many of you of course will
be thinking to yourself on earth is
estimating what does that mean what is
the difference between that and
hibernating joy you're one such person
the difference is that one is done for
cold and one is done for dry conditions
Esteve ting is done for dryness and
hibernation is done for coldness so in
very cold conditions animals will
hibernate tends to be a longer period
whereas estimating can be entirely
temporary so we had rain there's no real
reason why this is toys if a desert of
toys down here wouldn't come out because
it's certainly not cold enough for a
reptile not to be active I'm just
waiting for the Cobra to come out
I don't think we're quite at the end
there I've been talking about the
dangers of perhaps finding a rabid
number in here or angry Cobra or a
little two toys I think that's the end
there so it's about that deep that's
really quite deep that's about a foot
and a half and obviously we don't want
this any snakes to come after we don't
want to disturb the neutral toys but
like the most dangerous insect is
unquestionably the Anopheles mosquito
which of course carries malaria now you
probably didn't mean that because you
probably knew of course that malaria is
by far the most deadly thing out here
far more so than any of the mammals but
after I'm just trying to think after the
mosquito what would be the most
dangerous insect there very few
dangerous insects we have Hornets and
bees now we have blister beetles which
can cause your skin to blister but I
really don't think there's anything that
could kill you unless you have showed a
severe allergic reaction for example so
if you're allergic to bees well yes that
could kill you if you allergic to OPS's
that could kill you too but otherwise
really there's nothing out here that I
would feel afraid to have on my hand
other than the blister beetle in but
love bees and wasps can you think of
anything well I mean scorpions and
spiders obviously but they are strictly
speaking not insects are there yes
they're arachnids
yes in terms of Iraq means of course
there is there is a dangerous scorpion
via a nearly quarters and Anopheles
scope in the pear abuse at scorpions
yes that gives you malaria and a big
stink it will give you a very nice
device and then there of course are
ticks and ticks can give you tick bite
fever very very seldom fatal but it is
very unpleasant so that's a kind of
summary of the diseases that Envy
vertebrate in this area could give you
we have caught up with not fergus we've
caught up with Herbert and I'm going to
give an update from him there but what
do you have to tell us we're from here
all right
shall we go in let's go I'll follow you
tracks are going in here I think you've
heard that probably so we've got Steve
over there in fact I can hear his car
starting over there then we've got
Rick's on coming sort of from that
direction here and we've got us going
into this rock now so a good team to
find tündi than the sunday afternoon of
course if she really doesn't want to be
found she will not be found she was a
simply disappear
yes I heard them around there okay so
they'll be just saying they were
Franklin's a long calling here but here
you can find a track off a ton d there
she is so she came along here can you
see that Ferg there the front toes
there's a back pad she walked on through
this area we have got some alarm calling
to spot better sirs just over there
so as possible she's quite close by it's
all carefully and slowly I'll talk about
Misty's question which was our honey
badgers no active in winter or summer I
think there probably is no air
activities most times there's a school
pit not a squawk in a porcupine has got
in amongst this lot often you will find
about honey oh honey guides of honey
badgers honey guides probably almost
certainly more active during the
summertime of course they know it off
more bees active but they still have to
find food during the winter time so you
will find them live into this world some
very very angry chin spot lettuces but
we've just walked along that way so I
don't think that's nether lip it is
habet now just checking the ground she's
come along yeah this is one of those
tracks that is impossible for me to see
let alone show you on the camera see
isn't it really obvious you can see that
really clear track in the dirt they're
fantastically easy to see yeah anyway
while I continue to be mystified by her
but you can go along to Steve who will
be less mystifying
Herbie mystifies me all the time
birthday boy Herbie well we were just
moving around seeing if we can give them
a hand with them with any of their
tracking I heard some of those
Franklin's shouting as well and then we
didn't hear them anymore so we got to
keep to stopping listening stopping you
listening bring out your inner kudu
lots of birds shouting but none of the
birds that really give away the presence
of a leopard
so I think she was hunting or it might
have been her running away from Columbo
because there were tracks of of the
liquid or I think the larger of the two
tracks they're getting so similar in
size now are the tracks but you could
see my demonstration yesterday about
running you could see that she was
running the tracks were very very
disturbed and the distance between them
as well we're quite far we've got some
where we've got some people over there
now the bush walkers themselves just
through here maybe we can get a view of
them surround this termite mound
can they get that view of them coming
past the bushes deaf we just if we look
very carefully and closely there they go
led by her be followed by James and then
focus with the very long white antennae
so he's not spotting them are they
there was a rare sighting um I'm gonna
call it in on the radio stations we've
got lab Jackie I'm not gonna call it in
I don't think anyone would be too
interested to go and see anyone working
here anyway I'm sure lots of people
would be interested to go and see but I
think anyone working here would like to
rush off so they were coming up here I
can see by the tracks on the ground and
come to a junction in the road then the
tracks have now gone back in now
Herbie's on those we heard reports of
them this morning while we were on walk
and we came all the way from the south
of traffic on them but we never we never
got to any point where we found any
tracks it's very hard to track a leopard
when you don't have tracks it's not
called tracking then I suppose when we
will be in the area to assist where need
be toby is like a bloodhound once he
gets his his nose on the scent he wants
to find it I mean he was getting a bit
disappointed towards the end of our walk
because he couldn't find us said Herbie
we haven't seen tracks how are you
supposed to find it he likes to he said
he wants to find tündi for his birthday
he told me that he could have secretly
so we'd like to find him like to find
tiny for Herbie on his birthday wouldn't
we
Herbies birthday in Canada Day Oh
interesting
how interesting
okay well we'll go round around the
block and see how they get on with their
tracks maybe she's been moving maybe she
hasn't been I think that came up the
road we might turn down enough so we
might actually do the loop and just jump
onto the next one
so I think it's a very quiet day out
there on a Sunday
don't forget just head to your questions
and comments just tell us how you doing
what's going on what's going on in your
lives folks what's happening it's
happening that side what's the weather
like is it snowing whenever anyone is
anyone experiencing snow southern
hemisphere wonderful long days in the
summer delicate if you like today my
spirit animal Wow I haven't thought
about that I'm a Scorpio and I was born
in the year of the monkey and if you go
to a website called Prime Minister ology
you can find out that those two put
together actually make the combination
of the Raven so I think I'm a raven very
smart I didn't say that I read it that's
what it said in the in the primal
astrology it's actually quite a nice
website it puts together the year of the
Chinese year and their zodiac together
and if you've ever read your your star
side and felt that it's a little bit off
it's just not quite working then go and
check out your the your train is your
combined and then read what it is and
what it says and you'll be quite
surprised ok so what I'm going to do now
since I can you see that little pile
there can you see it
in the tree just on the ground and in
the tree
okay so jump off again it is a it is a
day for it isn't it it's going to jump
off and what's happened here has Scuba
Steve perhaps or another hippo has
walked along and he's put his bottom
over here and his all of his dung into
the tree and you completely see that
bye-bye that green grass then hmm it's
got quite a smell that's called take me
home smell because that's what the
hippos did for basically is like this is
the roots that they're moved through
certificate child universe my spirit
animal at the Dome metal very good that
could be true that could be very true
now what exactly does a hippo do this
for the Bushmen story goes if you never
heard of the Bushmen they are basically
the sand people the original inhabitants
of southern Africa before unbanned sue
Africans move down and white colonists
moved in from Europe they were original
people yeah lived in sustainably Stone
Age people and their belief in the hippo
is the hippo was the last animal created
by the Creator so he put together this
nose and this bum and these funny legs
and these beady eyes and these funny
ears and the hippo woke up one morning
went no I can't look like this look at
me I'm hideous um I'm round I'm fat my
legs are short I got a big mouth
huge nostrils beady eyes and funny
little ears please create please you
gotta allow me to hide in the water so
no one can look at me and laughs my
crazy said there's no way your mouth is
big you'll just eat all of the fish in
the pond the crocodile said there's no
way there's no way the birds no you
can't the hippo said creative please I
will every night I'll come out onto the
land and I'll defecate and I'll spread
my dong around and you can go through it
with a fine comb and look for any
fishbones to prove that I'm not eating
fish from the water so that is the story
of the hippopotamus quite a fun story I
liked the San Bushmen tales they were
all very sort of their ring true for our
sense of humor and our sort of what
would you say Majan a ssin
don't you agree sense hmm I'm not gonna
get that off for some time home is this
way since Arata left drag lavender
okay well we're gonna continue and we're
going to go around keeping attached on
the radio see what tracks are found by
her be where the meantime let's go over
to James and see how they're getting on
on the trail of Tandy well I was getting
along thinking about my spirit animal
and I decided that my spirit animal am I
sufficiently well-framed focus with the
light on my face is of the sea cucumber
I think that's quite a nice sea cucumber
yes thank you very much apparently my
spirit animal inspired me to these
colors there's Emma says so the sea
cucumber is my spirit animal and Kirsten
says it's because I'm as cool as a
cucumber
well Kirsten it's certainly not because
I like the sea cucumber am able to
excrete all of my organs a sea cuban per
camera is astoundingly able to do that
it is able to excrete all of its organs
from its backside and then rejuvenate
them or regenerate them now that is
quite an astonishing achievement which I
am unable to do but one should aspire to
a spirit animal that will who has
exceptional skills focus what is your
spirit animal spirit animal is the
immortal jellyfish some jellyfish are
apparently immortal it's not amazing
so fergus's spirit animal is the
jellyfish yes yes it does rather set you
up for a fall on the bush walk that is
the kind of hole where you would not
want to put your face it's definitely
still frequented by warthogs in fact
I've seen a warthog in this very burrow
resting there in the Morning Sun that's
a beautiful burrow it really is also
very difficult for a leopard to use it
for an ambush site
nice one good good one wolf-dogs this is
a lovely house
gorgeous environments beautiful garden
Jennifer Ehle I'm going to channel my
inner sea cucumber that's it I'm not
sure how that's going to help me but I'm
going to try and challenge all night in
this you might in a sea cucumber do you
hear that you would have heard that that
is the alarm call of a southern boo boo
I just saw dico running there I didn't
see a leopard running after it though
let's just keep going along here we
trust in her that's profound abilities
perhaps we should check with a final
control what the double red peril has as
a spirit animal I think they're both
should have spirit animals a little bit
like and fire ants siafu ants perhaps
without CF whence Kerstin thinks she's a
a Phoenix because she's risen from the
ashes I don't know how she's come to
that conclusion sunday spirit animal day
medicinal Mondays Sunday spirit animal
day now and Emma's spirit animal is a
platypus that's ridiculous
alright one of the very last flowers
that we have at the moment
is this that is kalanchoe and you can
see they're just starting to finish off
they'd normally got nice little red tips
to them now these sugars on director two
today says that her spirit animal was
the bald eagle well she's American of
course she is not mercifully bald and
like some others of us patriotic sunday
spirit animal day so sort of the last
flowers that there are there succulents
of course which means they can survive
in the difficult conditions of the dry
winter months when we can be rain free
for up to three months and then while
Herbert looks around this area I'll just
quickly show you this bush which I
really like simply because of its name
it is a porcupine bush or pyro austria
hystrix and there's a very spiny tree
without actually having thorns on it
and it does make pretty flowers and I
think the best part of it is that it has
this then we just move my hand there
it always has patches of this bright
yellow lichen and if you can see that
there Ferg variety yellow lichen on it
not much likes to eat it and it grows in
these lovely drainage line areas Oh
scenic I mean this is I'm afraid well
beyond the scope of my understanding of
the kingdom of the lichen you say what
species do we get I really don't know
there are lots and lots of them I could
probably try and find out for you but
I'm afraid I really don't know what
species of lichen we get here I don't
even know how many we get yeah I don't
know if there's a good diversity of bad
diversity I'm really not sure but they
of course Kerr on trees they occur all
over rocks in various parts of this
country and everywhere else so I'm not
sure which species we have here it's the
kind of sort of the organism that people
just refer to by the general name drunk
wine no way up through yeah down through
the strange sectioned where there are
giraffe tracks and off towards Herbert
so have you checked most of this block
this morning for us as did Vegas for
Tandy enter lumber and didn't come up
with anything so we're just checking the
last piece of the block she of course
could easily have moved during the
course of the morning and the afternoon
then we have another lovely tree here
that makes a beautiful red flower this
is the dwarf bourbon more Scotia Kappa
tartar that's this one here there are
actually two species it's this one here
and it's more fancied cousin of course
is Scotia Brackett patella or the
weeping burr beam which makes beautiful
rid dripping flowers that drip with
nectar come the early summer time so
this is Scotia Kappa tartar the dwarf
version I often think it must look at it
small favor to cousin and think to
itself why must I be so short and
stunted and that magnificence over there
towers over the preferred these are the
things we must ponder on a spirit animal
Sunday's
now I'm carrying a stick here that is of
the densest would we find it is the red
bush well it's also the most common
would we find here and it's okay for
making furniture minimum but basically
any tree that you can find that will
ghost grow straight enough will be
useful for furniture not thorns people
certainly have used before they don't
grow very wide and and this area I
suppose you could use Marilla would but
in this area there aren't a great number
of furniture sort of trees you could use
a Scotia back of it so that we can were
being I suppose but of all the South
African trees that have been used for
furniture making you probably find the
yellow wood will Podocarpus various
photo copper species would have been the
most favored and in fact I mean they
grow in sort of mist belt forests along
the escarpment and used to occur in huge
numbers and don't anymore because they
were cut down and often used for railway
sleepers that's how common there were
and they were used for railway sleepers
was tremendous tremendous pretty because
they're now an endangered tree and then
led woods you could use certainty but
it's obviously very dense woods are
quite difficult to work with
how what else what other woods could you
use mahogany we have there is mahogany
species that you produce but in this
area in any area where you find
elephants you're going to struggle to
find a tree that you're able to make
planks from
I don't think I've seen one mammal other
than that Steinbach today endangered
plants now child of the universe really
are testing my memory in my brain here
um certainly there are some protected
trees tile child of the universe that
we're not allowed to drive over or touch
the tambuti would be one of those the
jackal Barry the house Pyrus miss
piriformis would be one of those they'd
be considered vulnerable trees other
than that there are in parlor lilies
which we find from time to time they
could probably be considered relatively
vulnerable because of course they get
harvested for their looks and we make
beautiful pink and white candy striped
flowers at the end of the winter in fact
learn about now they'll start to flower
but I can't think of any other Oh
Edwards littles are definitely protected
you not allowed to chop them down so I
don't really know what else that would
be okay we're gonna carry on down
through here we're gonna start making
our way back towards home because of
course we need to be there in time for
darkness and then we'll get on the car
with the FLIR thermal camera the
meantime Steve of all know where he is
that inner what it's got
I'm taught will be interesting
thanks James you've got a squirrel and
his screws alarm calling as well as a
Franklin this cars looking a little
nervous isn't here but I think they
always look nervous let's just have a
listen there was also some Franklin's
giving a bit of a shot and also while we
wait here you might get another view for
an enormous female warthog that we saw a
moment ago we shall come back into the
frame
please go quiet
so drainage lime it's tündi really does
enjoy very very nice habitat for for
leopards for their Denning and honestly
these provides a perfect sort of areas
for fun y'all Arizona's Dacre what was
that ran across there
I think that was the squirrel that move
apart it lust has lost his nerve wonder
if this warthog is going to come out of
he was walking directly towards this
drainage line go straight back up to
before sook watering hole
good to just listen sometimes
you could probably can hear that
squirrel leather they know it's not it's
very very quiet that schools just
chirping a little bit he's not very
vocal there were some Franklin that was
the reason we stopped quiet indeed
okay let's carry on Brixton has joined
us in the in the fray for tracking and
the tracks that we had before on the
road he's arrived at me seems to think
indeed they are the fresher set and
they've cut back towards the dam
what's the watering hole so we're gonna
go back and have a look I mean there's a
good chance those niala that we saw
earlier and then parlor we saw earlier
were a little bit frightened because
there maybe could smell or sense and
leopard watching them and just keep our
eyes peeled and drive very very slowly
as a Herbie and James and Ferg make the
long walk all the way back it is quite a
walk we did it this morning there's very
nice walk
humor I haven't heard anything about
uncle homers I mean there was rumbles of
the sticks being around chitwa sort of
to the east of chitwa maybe to the south
but with regards the oklahoma's I've no
idea I don't have I don't have any
friends in the West
it sounds very bad doesn't it Taylor
seems to know everybody but she didn't
communicate anything that with me so I
don't know I haven't heard anything
about the rumors in in two weeks they
just like that when you think you've
lost them and materialize again but I've
no doubt the arrival of the workers
their vocal mails the three newcomers to
the area will be upsetting things and
those females would definitely be sort
of going in areas where they feel a
little bit more comfortable there's that
Franklin again or the spur foul that at
else / foul it's busy shouting a moment
before but not not the Leopards sort of
shot that you get quite used to do get
quite spooked though by things it has
gone back to feeding in the city a nice
varied diet and walk around and pluck up
insects and termites and seeds and
scratching the ground can get bulbs and
tubers and corms from the grasses
feeding on grass itself you don't even
decomposing digestive sort of elephant
and and runner dunk incredibly
camouflaged when they want to be
deceptive sit down and they're gone
there we go yes you're feeding on some
seeds as well nice very died getting all
the the vitamins in and that looks like
a male you can see on the back of the
leg there's a spare hmm and mother do
they got a very nice spotted front and
that makes it very camouflaged and even
when they stand still this is just gone
isn't it these guys are very reliable
when it comes to spotting leopards as
we've seen we've got that very sort of I
can't do it very well there's not the
high pitched charting Franklin shot it's
that it's this really strange little
kering sound that they're doing they
often sitting in the bush looking at the
lipid yeah food sins are there but it
sounds nothing like that loo perhaps
yeah that was the lesser and sins I call
that was coming through there you might
have heard it on the ambient coming back
up to this is the junction here I'll
show you what we've done just to give
you an idea of where we are and where
James has been walking and kind of those
of you who are quite new to the show if
you are wondering all these names we've
been throwing out we've got some very
nice maps so let me just get on a flat
piece of ground while I get on the flat
piece of ground I can't help myself
but show you some dung at the same time
I'm going to put that on the dashboard
that's where it belongs there we go it's
a very Dungy dashboard today and there's
only two animals that can have dung that
look like this first of all you can see
it's quite dark in color these are
actually individual each of these
individual pilots I see that's a two
pilots there you can see they're stacked
together which indicates a diet of a lot
of moisture either they drink a lot of
moisture or they get a lot of moisture
in the dung but in the wet season will
dubious tongue can look just like this
just like this but looking over to the
side it's not in a in a midden at all
it's just a pile on the side of the road
and so there's this there's another
animal that's it likes to all that has
done just like that but reason I stopped
was actually for us to have a look at
what we've done today so here is our
home base just over there and the
bushwalk team has kind of walked through
this area here and that's where we had
them just before walking and we've kind
of come around the top come around this
way and we're now there again so we've
done a big loop and the tracks we head
of town Yentl lumber were over here and
they seem to cut back towards the dam so
Rickson is busy following his other
tumor guide he helps us out quite
so she's probably in the serious she was
over here for a couple of days with her
daycare kill just up there so there's a
good chance she hasn't gone too far okay
so the other animal that likes to to
pool a cat or what likes to I suppose
that over much of a choice have a show
Katherine well done it is indeed it is
indeed and here when we have a look at
the difference between the water back at
the top pellets are often irregular
shaped and clamped together so often
meaning pretty much all the time whereas
blue Valda best is like that at the
bottom here the pellets are clumps
together but the shape doesn't change
you see if they are clump together when
there's a lot of moisture in the in the
diet they'll still be peanuts like that
whereas water buck if they're not
they're generally are clump together
anyway but they're irregular shaped like
that can you see let's go back to our
our sample and you can clearly see that
these are not brown - sort of oval
pellets they're all irregularly shaped
all of them not just those to the entire
pile of them really and that's because
of the enormous amount of moisture that
waterbug have to drink there it can
about 60 liters of water now if you work
that out a buffalo which is three times
the size of a water buck feeds on or
drinks half of that it's a lot of water
isn't it anyway buffer goes back onto
the pile yes that is exactly Emma while
they're called water back they like to
see the Kurt in and around the watering
holes
ah yes
hello Malaika well you know you want to
know about what I said earlier got to do
with what water on today I was wondering
when someone was going to come back with
that I put that little bit of a
cliffhanger there didn't I well
essentially white rhino dung is made up
of only grass there's no medicinal value
in it and I don't know exactly what the
reason is but traditionally locals
believe it to be bad luck to to burn
around our dung elephant dung is good
for keeping our mosquitoes and flies and
lots of medicinal value but just to them
burning white rhino dung is a no-no now
sometimes to try and get the answers
from from people why there's no real
answers it's no that's just not done in
their culture local locally in this
young guns people that I've met they
told me that so when you ask them they
look at you like why do you need to know
the answer that that's just not done and
that's kind of the way it works in
Africa suppose it doesn't have to be a
reason Marat since it's just the way it
is you know I think us with our Western
mentality we have to have a reason and
an answer for everything but our chair
just is for example I worked with the
gentleman will serve of shunga and
Tsonga descent if we went our own game
driving the first animal we saw was a
great acre he would insist that we
stopped drove back to camp everybody get
off the car get back on the car again
otherwise we're not gonna see any
animals and now that's a traditional
belief he has you have to respect that
regardless of what your thoughts might
be on the matter and so it happens to us
a couple of times and then we went back
and got on the vehicle and went out and
things are really good but if I had to
push forward and deny him that he would
he would actually get never tried it but
he'd probably get quite upset you know
it's it's just not done so he never told
me why he says just bad luck and if it
was it bad luck just is yeah I hope that
makes sense to all of you we've got a
respect cultures regardless of where
they come from or but even if we think
they might seem a bit strange or funny
or or whatever there might be there are
cultures to some people and beliefs and
some of them are passed on a lot of them
were passed
bye-bye words no no written no written
script passed out from grandfather to
sudden again and again and again over
many many generations and it's just the
way it is okay well we almost back it
before sub watering hole maybe Scuba
Steve will be playing a little bit nice
this time but let's go see how nasty
James is playing on the way back a scuba
Steve will not be playing nicely you'll
be lying as he always is doing
absolutely nothing here we have a
warthog on foot which is just wonderful
now we are far enough away from him not
to think that he has to run away not for
him not to think that he has to run away
and he's in the open which is unusual
we've just told him
Tandy's probably here she might try and
eat you but if you could just stand
there for a little while we'll put you
on screen and then we should probably
vacate the area sometime fairly soon we
haven't found any further tracks of
tandy we think Steve's probably on some
fresher tracks but we've obviously got
to get back towards the house not the
house of the camp Wow look at that he's
starting to graze that's brilliant
completely relaxed I keep saying he
because I'm assuming a young male
because he's on his own
they're getting away their focus
um actually it's a female and she's
pregnant I think it's very interesting
indeed now they live in burrows of
courses Palin has realized but Palin
they don't dig their own burrows they
normally use burrows dug by our Fox in
termite mounds all in the ground and our
roads Palin are generally not places
that after Fox go digging they will dig
in the middle of the blocks and in the
termite mounds that's where the warthogs
go so no the burrows do not block the
roads yeah that's a song I think she's
quite pretty now to find a song on her
own is not very common and often in
Sanders or 2 or 3 but as yeah Zimmer
says her tusks are massive certainly
she's a youngster but I said she was a
female cousin explained that to you
after you've been doing that quite a lot
of late I didn't explain that to you um
she only had one set of warts on her
face as opposed to two sets touch the
male's would have and now as you look to
this angle you can really clearly see
that there is a lack of equipment at the
back that would indicate very quickly if
that was the mole but let's have one
sorry one last look therefore because
her tusks really are very large it just
indicates that she's not a youngster
well chart I would go the other way if I
were you that what pig will be difficult
for Tony to take they're very wily
they're very strong and they're dense so
her mass is probably about seven or
eight kilos heavier than Tandy and while
Tandy killed a niala that was probably
double her mass the other day it
wouldn't have been nearly as wire you'll
compact or difficult to get hold of as
that water peak over there
that's the story of the wart figure now
there's something else I wanted to tell
you yes right so on hearing that Steve
said locals do not burn rhino dung
because it's bad luck I said to her but
can run her down be use for anything he
said yes you boil it that and hippo dunk
you can boil it and drink the tea and
that will make your stomach feel better
if you've got a nasty stomach a fantasy
very useful for that and then we got
chatting and he said well you know hippo
fat is in fact used to bring cows into
East hrus so obviously if you have a car
and you wanted to produce your milk you
need to make sure there's air falls
pregnant fairly regularly and one of the
ways to do that is to rub it in the
appropriate place with hippo fat
apparently that's quite effective so
very interesting thought hippo and rhino
there and something else a vital
importance I needed to tell you I have
since forgotten because I can only keep
three things in my mind at once wonders
the warthog - was the tea from the rhino
dung and three was the hippo fat there's
the only three things I can keep in my
mind at the same time sorry about that
yeah we're going to keep walking we need
to keep walking the Sun is sitting as I
said it must give back now to try and
get on our vehicle Steve I think has
probably now approached the waterhole
where the world's most boring
hippopotamus is sitting let's hope that
he does something today
while scuba is not playing the game so
we thought maybe we would entice him out
with a cup of tea didn't work
beautiful afternoon this is one of them
one of the best things about being out
in the bush and something that if you
ever go on game job you will experience
one in the afternoon one in the morning
a little coffee sundowner break either
in the morning obviously on the
afternoon depending on that with the Sun
is at and so their special moments you
sit somewhere quiet beautiful view you
can either sit around and chat with each
other with the guide or what I always
enjoy doing is going off to the side and
just listening to the noises yourself
smelling your own smells identifying our
own dung and then asking the guide is
this hippo poo is this how did I brought
in a sundowner brought him oh he likes
my Ito's doesn't he
I forgot we didn't have any em didn't
have any meant scuba quite a sulky face
last time I even made coffee for him he
didn't he wasn't even here when I got
you and the coffee's boring coffee is
boring scuba needs more than coffee
doesn't you know he can check them
heaters down now tell you that what
Scuba Steve he is away two weeks ago
okay well we've had up settling moment
at the watering hole it's not too much
going on here but we're going to move
around and check either side of it
because there's a very good chance that
Tonya telomer might be near and about
here somewhere not too far away and
maybe maybe it's going to start moving
shortly but nothing like a little moment
of clarity or silence just to
contemplate your day
let go of any negativity you might have
generated on this Sunday why generating
there but negativity on a Sunday
difficult they have rest most people
beautiful
as peaceful spot yeah just remember what
we are thankful and grateful for the
little things very small things a cup of
tea by watching I'm very thankful for
that
ok well if we get a little bit of water
bucket dunk still in my car you're all
excited about heat oh I get quite
excited too I must say
I must say what does that is it does
miss it is sends us on the other side
there we've got a little delve about to
come down to drink it's going to be
beautiful light just straight there a
little emerald spotted wood down there
is a beautiful M from the wing Oh
manis gone there's a tricky business
coming down one at a time as a bird to
come and drink because lots of raptors
in Iran they might come and take you out
really I find I'm quite perplexed as to
why a bird would have such colorful bits
on the wing Isabella you are most
welcome to come and join us next time
for a sundowner and as always beautiful
and I'm a crested Franklin's who've been
eating lots of seeds today well no dark
need to quench their thirst shortly go
away bird on the other side the washing
hole we'll keep our ears open I'm gonna
have a look that side we might be able
to find ourselves some spots while we
wait and listen let's see how these
Franklin get on their intention is quite
clear they're heading towards the water
they're coming into in twos safer in
twos but it's even safer in a group when
you feed a lot of dry material a lot of
seeds you have to drink you have to
drink
that's why barmen makes so much money
when they feed you nuts horses you to
drink and spend money mmm it's the time
of day for a sundowner and they also got
the view of the Sun beautiful you can
see the difference now and that the
natal spur fowl with the orange beak and
orange feet these guys have got the
black beak and the pinkish legs and that
white super cilium coming over the eye
okay I think they've had enough maybe
some more a very camouflage but not when
they're out in the open like that very
necessary time of day okay well car
coming in I think for their son Donna so
we gonna move off and give them their
spot
afternoon party Bush turkey
yeah well sins it likes to call them the
bush chicken so yeah
the bush turkey they don't make the same
sort of sound
turkeys are the funniest things in the
world the way that they walk and I'm not
gonna do it I'm not gonna do it but
that's gonna be on on live forever
I do the turkey turkey sound so sounds
like we can do it they sense since he's
never heard of turkey isn't he's he's
smiling like this and famous which means
he knows exactly what a turkey is
okay well here we are gonna come around
and just check these little roads in and
around the dam and see if we can come up
with any spotted get let's see what we
can find on the silver cluster leaf here
you can see the Sun is setting rather
gloriously on Sunday afternoon here is
the silver cluster leaf tree a deciduous
tree that is losing all of its leaves
you can see and therefore not to be
expected that we should find too much
going on on the tree but we might find
the of spider's web that is may fit into
the leaves and we're also going to taste
the leaves because now that they're dry
I'm wondering if they're rather bitter
nasty tannin taste hasn't gone
it's certainly better than it is when
it's fresh but it's not nice le yes
spiders are around not many though
you'll find the odd spider lurking
around probably mostly the spiders at
hanging around under logs like velu
spiders and daddy longlegs spiders those
that you the widow spiders in lecto dick
truss for example the brown buttons the
black button spiders you'll find him but
most of the spiders that are out in the
open the old web spiders and some of the
what else no you find tropical tent web
spiders you'll find in the winter time
but be dormant but you'll find them or
almost dormant but you'll find them and
but also the community in there spiders
you definitely find them in the winter
time but most of the old web spiders now
I think they only last for a season and
of course the most obvious example of
that would be the golden orb web spider
magnificent spider that only lasts for a
season huge spider size in my hand that
many of you would have seen them before
then there were the baboon spiders are
equivalent of the tarantula which you
would find certainly in the wintertime
much of the cover over there they do
they put a silken cover over the tops of
their webs I think in the wintertime and
I'm trying to think of a trapdoor spider
I imagine that a trapdoor spider would
also be around but you know all of these
things will become far less active
during the winter months and you must
also remember that they their you know
their metabolism slowed down their
exothermic which means they don't make
their own body heat which means they can
allow their body temperatures their
metabolisms to slow down and just sort
of sickness update of semi dormancy
until times a bitter mammals are not
born of that
luxury we must maintain a metabolism to
maintain our body temperatures birds are
the same and so the advantage of that of
course is that we can live in very cold
climates where most other animals cannot
live but it does mean of course that we
must keep eating we cannot go dormant we
cannot go into a permanent state of
torpor or dormancy and this it is with
the maintenance of body heat and I
suppose you have a good example of that
would be a bear in hibernation they
maintain body heat I think they do drop
their temperature slightly but not as
much as something like a reptile is able
to just making sure that what I'm saying
to you there is truth I'm pretty sure it
is but the great example in this
particular area is a bush baby Bush
babies do it every day they go into a
state of torpor they drop their body
drop their body temperatures much but
they certainly slow their metabolisms
down go into very deep sleep to the
extent that if you find a bush baby in
the day you can pick them up and they'll
lie in your hand as they slowly wake up
them in their freaked out and run away
I've never done it myself but I have
seen it done what was that about I'm fed
of completely lost my train of thought
there we had a question minimum oh why
the spiders need webs
well they need depends on the spider
really all spiders can make silk as far
as I'm aware the orb web spiders quite
obviously need this look in order to
make webs that catches their prey some
of the splitting spiders will spit silk
and sort of silken lines at their prey
catch them like that the hunting spiders
and the widow spiders will grab their
prey inject them and then wrap them up
in silk and so while the Earthmen
particularly deceptively flat piece of
ground there so while the preys while
the venom is taking effect
they can't thrash about and kick and
move away there
backed up and trussed up in silk so
that's very important cilix used
extensively for egg sacks keeps the eggs
safe so they make very strong egg sacks
which keeps the eggs safe during the
time that they're being incubated so the
myriad myriad functions for silk in the
case of the baboon spider it's used
certainly to truss up prey it's used to
line the web it's used to create a
topping for the web same with a funnel
web spider another funnel web spider the
trapdoor spider which will create a
trapdoor of silk and dirt on top of that
silk so it really is very very valuable
I guess it's a little bit like asking
why are the humans find any kind of the
word I'm looking for
fiber useful I mean using for myriad
things our clothing our ropes everything
else focusing very well walking
backwards it's most impressive all right
I'm not sure what's happening with Steve
out though in nearly home get Hans windy
for kids get across to him
thanks James yes well we we've done a
big loop around and them sends up its
gonna go back and just behind this bush
here is a beautiful little Steinbach and
maybe we can get it in the light tell me
when you're happy sins II like that sir
just put his head down forget to take my
foot off the brake it's just a Steinbach
fee busy feeding he's obviously not
concerned by us but the cross is not
very tall and is amazing how they just
disappear in me it's a strategy hiding
way
wonder if he's also waiting to enjoy the
sunset after Taylor discussion the other
day a doubt it's a doubt animals enjoy
that the coming of the night
very little isn't he fully grown animal
for those of you who've never seen a
Steen Mach before it is indeed lovely
light em maybe you do don't look
directly at the Sun give you a little
bit of blindness just at that
so we were coming around just onto the
northern sort of fire break with before
sook and we're gonna come around on two
before sook damn again
very very pretty
do forgive me for showing you the Sun
twice but we couldn't help ourselves and
a nice LED wood tree just to add some
color everyone's enjoying the pretty
sunset I think we were all thoroughly
enjoy these moments all we need is a
leopard to be perched in that tree down
to his sensor and my time in the Kruger
Park we used to get leopards often in in
dead LED wood trees like rats it was a
very characteristic sort of shot
the bush slowly starts to quieten down
animals returning to their their roosts
or birds anyway predators probably
started to do some stretches and some
yarns getting ready to go and drink and
maybe do some hunting hello Jay you know
my favorite bush food is well hmm very
good question
the berries off of am for the Oklahoma
tree off of the bra anemone the brown
are very beautiful very very flavorful
also the the seeds off of the sour plum
the pods fruits sorry when they're up
can be very very nice and then I would
say that the fruits off of the the
sandpaper raisin are also very very
delicious when you get them in the right
stage and I do enjoy a buffalo thorn
leaf from time to time lots of things
Archer to eat I'm a vegetarian by the
way so those are all the things that I
like fruits and vegetables
Marcia you want to know what plant I can
survive on in the sabi sands it's a very
good question I don't think I think we
would struggle not yeah it's still buck
what's he looking at
dies okay what could I survive on I'm
trying to think you get what's that
spinach called against Enzo do you
remember the spinach the locals eat
spinach art in Morocco
there's a wild sort of weed that grows
it's quite a good substitute what's
going on going where birds are shouting
they might just be coming together for
their roost Green it's important to pay
attention to these sounds when you see
him since it's just up there I'll go
back a touch hello go back have a look
at what he's looking at
might just be that time of day or le as
I think he's also enjoying the sunset to
be honest
now where's my friends where's my
friends he wants to know where the
after-party is where's the after party
where's the after the sunset party gonna
be so lots of fruits around Jackyl berry
fruits are quite tasty when they're ripe
um you know
neeyala berries you don't get yeah so
lots of fruits there's not too many
plants such a know we could eat there's
a few tubers and bulbs some lilies who
might be able to eat okay well as we
watched the sunset in the distance let's
go over to James who has managed to find
my herd of wildebeest
I didn't know that Steve owned herds of
all the best but I'm very pleased to
know that this is his herd of all the
best i Steve's herd of wildebeest I
wonder when he bought them oh he bought
them from and it's quite impressive I've
never owned a herd of wildebeest I
didn't know they were purchasable in
fact I've just had a an impression from
Herbert about what's going on with the
impala and he says that what they're
doing is talking to each other as
follows he says their body language is
saying is it safe to go down though I
don't know let's check carefully let's
just look around carefully okay maybe we
can't no no no yes no no that's good no
wait yes okay okay let's have a drink
just a few of us at a time that the rest
of you look around that of course is the
caution of the impala is very important
otherwise there'd be devoured
apparently Steve's her does have labels
on it now I'm assuming in the ear orange
tags with an S on him I'll have to get
closer to see it can see the colors have
completely faded from the scene and
that's because the sun's just gone down
Logan these questions are really hate
being asked because I'm not sure of the
answer can wildebeest get tuberculosis
I'm gonna say yes they probably can I'm
going to say also that I don't think it
affects them as far as I understand it
most cloven hoofed ruminants there
aren't any unclothed ruminants but most
there are some cloven hoofed non
ruminants there are no single hoofed
ruminants that we've cleared that up
as far as I'm aware most cloven hoofed
ruminants can get tuberculosis of the
bovine variety and no could who can I
know it does affect them obviously
Buffalo can I think feel the best can
but I'm gonna say that it doesn't affect
them hugely like it does the Buffalo I
might be wrong there I'm very happy to
accept a correction from a clever of you
er lovely evening senior and parlors
frolicking about having a nice drink II
haven't seen any leopards that might
want to eat them no lions and as I've
said before that Vil the best herd
really has had a very good time at of
light because one would have expected
that the one would have expected the
Lions to have come to eat a few of the
Fulda beasts I would have thought an
apparently summer you're asking is the
equipment on the tree the damn camera I
don't know which tree we're talking
about basically what happens with the
dam cam where it is now is it's winter
position
and there is a bit of equipment
underneath it that is used for the dam
cam there's a light underneath it
there's a microphone and there's a box
with some power cables in it
and that's the winter position then when
the actual dam fills up there is another
tree which is to the south east of via
of the tree with the camera in it now
then there's a light there and another
box so that's what's going on there oh
and then you're probably talking about
the nest cam in the water itself there
is a log that stretches out over the
surface of the water and that log has a
nest cam on it and I'm not sure if it's
live at the moment it certainly will be
fairly soon so that gives you an idea of
what's going on there
they're nearly home as you can see we
started off walking through this area
like this set since to finish off
walking like this I suppose
this is my Sunday evening power walk
suppose it would have been much funny if
I'd fallen over and trips and fallen
over ground my nose into the dirt yes
absolutely Jason when times get tough at
this very waterhole we have seen
elephants and hippopotamus having a
standoff we've seen elephants buffalo
and hippopotami having a standoff over
the water so yes they're all herbivores
I've seen aggressive interactions
between them often what happens if there
is a sort of meeting of wildebeest and
Impala they will just stay out of the
impala will stay out of the way of the
bigger animals Buffalo will sometimes
come down here and if there are an
Impala gnarley' anything smaller they'll
chase them away you know won't allow
them to drink at the same time and it's
very simple to figure out who's going to
win those interactions the bigger you
are the more access you're going to have
to the resource that is well in short
supply but in general you don't see any
interactions between them any aggressive
interactions whose is just no point
really unless it's over water which of
course should be pristine for us as
human beings as it also becomes
increasingly in short supply it's
entirely possible in one day we will
fight big Wars over access to water and
I'll be very unpleasant that but doesn't
happen
all righty three minutes from home we'll
jump on Wendy
extract the thermal camera let's see
what we can find for the lawsuit by here
is Steve at the moment any idea where
Steve is no he's bumbling around not
sure where with this impressive rock
while we wait for this information
forged in the bowels of the earth many
millions of years ago beautiful this is
a volcanic rock see if I can hear the
history oh the things that seen let us
head to the north now mister Volvo is
driving
while we're parked at the moment having
a look at a herd of kuru and James
questioning why my herd of all the best
well when our challenge draft to a
territorial display I took over that
herd of all the best but taking over
that mail of all the best midden so
there we go here is a beautiful herd of
kuru and she is busy feeding on her aide
the bush willow nice green leaves I must
have a very good root system because we
are on this sort of the slope here here
on the top so it's thought to have green
leaves that must be really really well
anchored in the ground there I wonder if
she knows what a nice tea red bush
willow makes nice an antimicrobial can
also be applied as an enema I don't
think she knows about that though David
certainly does he refused to take one
but very good for steaming lots of
medicinal value in the red bush water
leaves and by soaking the leaves you get
all that beautiful stuff out she is
selecting the very green ones to get the
moisture not just the benefits of the
plant themselves but the protein as well
as the moisture the browsing animals can
get a little bit more moisture out of
the vegetation than your grazing animals
and could who are making most of the
leaves that are around because in the
next month or two there's gonna be
almost nothing left with regards to
browse it was a young male
mr. woohoo altitude mister we will do
the interesting am indeed in very
interesting years you say back like they
are enormous and so you can see that the
could who uses their years for for
listening
they've got enormous ability to perceive
sounds just like your fruit-eating bats
or like your insect-eating bats with
their with the ultrasound and then as
the koodoo strategy is to stand very
still if a lion or leopard sees them and
to hear the slightest footfall as it
moves through the long grass
Larry yeah that's a very good thought
about could lose spots or straps
influencing humans and their paint well
you know the paint aspect of the kudu or
the colors is about sort of camouflage
breaks out their three-dimensional
characteristic and I think in humans the
paint came about as a form as a form of
sort of okay well we get back to that
because the teams of is James has got
his in Yala's but he dancing a
ridiculous
captivating and very beautiful dance
being performed here by a Nala bull
there's another one to his left hand
side doing exactly the same thing this
one was making much more of an effort to
cut can you see the second one another
one's ignoring him completely in having
a meal this chap trying to say look I'm
very big and strong another one saying
don't waste my time because mental
distill up as he looks at us and see if
I can inspire him to do the same thing
does he look like he's impressed I mean
he's doing what the other gnarley' did
to him this is the human dance what
about the sprinkler
I've got his attention running man don't
like the running man do you know what
the string dance the worm your hips
before you that's there anyone I can do
with them
my hips my knees together then there the
string dance now Oh young kids do the
string art I'm not a young kid anymore
folks sprinkler that's the one you like
the best
move off yeah sprinkler good for you he
knows he's in top herbert good night and
happy birthday may you wake up tomorrow
not feeling anything like you're 78
years good morning
okay
who wants to be James oj dazzle the Nala
does I think I think that the knee allas
o oj and the niala want to be James I
can assure you that neither do you want
to be James I must apologize for the
infrastructure there that's just the
back of the lodge we weren't planning on
seeing that in yada and he just happens
to be near the camp and it's one of the
reasons they are so confiding is that
they're used to being around people so
that was very pleasant to see them y'all
are doing his dance and to dance for him
they do it so often for us times if
please show him some dancing hi I'm not
going to Wolf's home in the meantime
let's go across the Steve well thank you
James I would love to know how that
niala waltzing dance went very good
I'm sure it went splendidly I was very
interested to see a yellow bulldog
speaker on the kudu we had a yellow
Bulldog speck of a on the kudu which was
very cool to see because we don't see
too many of them in the while they were
almost completely extinct in southern
Africa because of dips and cattle dips
and that we can the eggs in the breeding
obviously didn't kill the adults but
over time that made the eggs very weak
and obviously the individuals were
inbreeding and if you're not breathing
you end up dying out oh sorry about that
but ewt endangered wildlife trust the
introduction or reintroduction of
yellow-billed oxpeckers back from from
botswana has been a real success and if
you've ever looking at a herd of buffalo
you should look very closely you'll
probably find a number of yellow
bulldogs peckers on there not just the
red belt which is very very cool
they do more of a sort of plucking
minner combing and their beak is half
red half yellow which makes it quite
easy to identify
miss Miller about ox pickers have less
this year I don't think so I think
there's the normal sort of amount we
just don't have the herds of Buffalo
coming food the oxpeckers seemed to
follow herds of Buffalo like kids at a
candy store it's just a huge amount of
ticks on Buffalo and when there's a herd
of them plenty plenty so I haven't
actually seen I think I've seen
yellow-billed here on Juma in the last
six months maybe that's the third time
I've seen them so very cool very cool to
see and picture we weren't able to get
them few though but we'll try harder
next time
we couldn't prevent you going to see
James doing his dancing now could we I'm
sure lots of screen shots were made
we're following up on them a bit later
oh my god there's the first bat of the
evening and are we gonna be able to get
him is moving very quickly there's God
it's insect insect eating bats oh you
can see him children not a vampire bat
moving very fast he just come out from
somewhere I don't know where he's
feeding on insects that are flying in
the air bouncing off waves that are
bouncing off from his head very well
evolved mammal and has taken to the sky
nocturnal to avoid the daytime
competition of pets
scenic you want to know what the most
common bug in the bush that this bat
might be eating it to be little sort of
flying midges of sorts like didn't
couldn't really tell you my my knowledge
on Beth
food is quite limited I know that you
get bats that eat fruit and then bats
that eat insect so I'll assume there's
lots of little flying bugs in the sky
that they're busy feeding on but the
most common insects in the bush would
I'm sure be termites and ants different
species of them but I doubt that those
insect eating bats are feeding on any of
those although you do sometimes get the
flying el aids where there's lots of
insects around even though you don't see
them they're very very small
okay well we have done a big loop lots
of loops around boof Asuka damn no luck
at all with regards to well here we have
a late night feeding hornball mere arts
a bit late aren't you sir
here's that yep I was just trying to get
a last snack in there guys he's looking
for termites
very happy this is the Red Bull torn
book hmm he wasn't invited indeed he's
not having a little bit of a snack on
his own
lots of termites around on the ground
potentially ants
to hear that
I heard something off to the right
okay well long ago I believe James's
return to camp and will be joining us
again shortly out on Wendy
so folks how is everyone doing out there
we still we're still out and about
Wow Larry so Larry's read that bats can
eats over a thousand mosquitoes that
that is a lot of mosquitoes now all
they're after the mosquito or the blood
in its belly I wonder I wonder
okay so nighttime is coming through
almost time to put in a layer and I
think we're going to be putting on the
infrared shortly sensor you just tell me
when you'd like to put it on
some more late night feeding Birds here
minami you've always got that one
question don't you in the day do I think
animals have souls well I think
everything's gonna solve everything's
connected in some way everything needs
to be respected anyway you know if if I
if you ask me if I think think
everything gets reincarnated is
something else I don't know I really
don't know we've got some virtual
starlings on the side yeah we're talking
about them earlier this morning or this
afternoon you see the much longer tail
the dark dark eye
do I think animals have souls is
certainly I think everything is gonna
got something and we need to respect
them the word soul I'm not quite sure
how to define a soul really Coralie put
words on on the description of it
it's all the energy I think everything's
energy everything's connected everything
is living in harmony and balance
everything has a purpose
Sharon you want to know about energy and
trees in particular and I think
everything's connected to to the earth
and energy itself I think flows through
everything you can all agree or disagree
with me but I mean first of all there's
energy in in the food we eat that it
moves from the bottom to the top and
that is the one form of energy I mean
without the Sun we don't survive you
know there's there's definitely energies
and and vibrations deep down when you
get in tune with that you can feel them
I mean the Buddha himself went to a
level where you could see the body
arising and passing away as very small
subatomic particles and in the early
nineteen hundreds of scientists went and
actually examined that and saw that
actually everything is made up of
subatomic particles that are just moving
against each other and the ability you
have to change someone's outlook on by
saying a word or by looking at someone
it's quite incredible actually
who ever noticed that huh someone can
say something or look at you in a
certain way and it can completely change
how you feel how is that possible
without energy possibly the way we react
to things to perceptions of what things
are
so energy not just in heat but in
vibrations I think everything has got a
vibration and before you react to
anything or experience anything it
starts off as a feeling you know in you
suddenly feel angry you didn't feel
angry first you you felt something in
the pit of your stomach and then you
reacted to it to when you feel scared
about something it's the same it's a
feeling inside it's an energy inside and
then your body reacts to it I don't know
if you all agree if you feel in love you
don't suddenly just feel in love
something happens inside nkz yeah your
fingers and your toes start to tingle
and then you feel love you know it's all
of this it's all energy you can feel it
in your hands yeah I think it's all very
relevant
I do I really do so I think plants have
energy enabled to communicate
I mean they've done some some studies
some people have refuted them some
people have agreed with them where they
a Japanese scientist took took rice or
he took water for example and he said
things to the water and he froze it and
took photographs and by saying happy
saying I love you to the water generated
beautiful crystals inside the water and
then saying I hate she generated very
weird chemical crystals inside and then
he did the same with summer ice you've
got some rice in a in water and they
said the same thing he said I love you
to the one and it blossomed and it
looked all good and he said I hate you
to the other one and it looked quite
gross and then he ignored the third one
and the third one was even worse than
the one that he said I hate you too
because I hate you at least his energy
isn't it ignoring someone is no energy
it's just what if you got okay we're
just gonna go around this way
about that y'all is up ahead so some
people have taken his science to be
truthful and some people have also said
that he doctored a lot of that but why
do we why do a lot of people pray before
before eating why do some people pray
before eating you know your blessing the
food before going in at churches a lot
of ceremonies around the world holy
water and think what makes holy water
exactly that's the blessing that goes
onto the water certain energy really
just water but something has been given
to the water but it's still water well
we've got some some impalas trying to
test their energy up ahead here mark you
want to know if we got wild dog while we
do they come in and out and the
absolutely love Impala is - male Impala
don't realize that they're attended an
entire full moon ago anyway they're
still going to expand on their own
energy but while dog do move they don't
have a territory per se at the area that
they're the home range that their cover
is enormous and they can you know most
of the sabi sands essentially is the
wild dogs terrain and they don't sort of
stay in one spot for too long they're
constantly moving in search of food and
only once they den down once the female
has has pups will they find an area to
sort of call home for a while but they
arrange an enormous distance they want
really good stamina and they don't
really have a smaller territory like
leopards or even lions they just keep
moving because they've got such a high
metabolism and energy expenditure that
they need to eat regularly and that
requires and lots of running
mr. guys aren't having a serious fight
that just just look a little bit of
testosterone inside they're trying to
get out and and maybe they're trying to
warm up for the evening but those ridged
horns on the tip of them is very sharp
but the ridges on them you can see from
the side actually aid in in the
grappling the horns together preventing
them from slipping but these two
survived the season I don't think either
these two are reproductive this year but
they survived they they watched and they
learned to me they realized what not to
do and how to do it and their interests
are piqued and they've practiced a bit
and next year we might see these two in
the running there's a little a 7-month
rods trying to get involved he's like
hey hang on how does this work
there we go look at the footwork he's
looking at at all taking some notes you
can see his horns are very small he's
very young you know the younger brother
who just gets in the way Emma thinks he
looks like a referee just watching he
knows it's gonna be his turn sometime it
could see it's not a serious fight they
keep missing their horns are
interlocking and then moving potentially
very dangerous if you get one of those
in the eye you're gonna hurt yourself a
bit one of those in the in the lung
you're going to really hurt yourself
ladybird yes rutting season essentially
the the last full moon in April but all
beginning of May through to the next
full moon so pretty much a 29 day
calendar between two full moons that is
essentially when the female and Pilar
come into East just normally in a band
that month of May obviously can move a
little bit further forward depending on
that full moon and in the next full moon
and during that period the males go
absolutely berserk because the the
females are in E stress and they roaring
and they're shouting and screaming to
the world and chasing each other around
and that is done that has done
whole full-moon ago and we're ready
another whole cycle past and we're going
to be going into infrared if we can in
about five four we don't have the light
on we need to put the lights on I
thought we were going to put we had the
lights on already but we've been on a
segment for so long we haven't stopped
to put it on so we actually need to put
it on that is what we needed to do so
we'll be putting it on shortly since I
can probably start doing it now can we
put on to that let's let's put on the
valle de BS chair since we're still
waiting for James to get up so it's
still nice we can still see them it's
not that dark this is I think the heard
James saw on his way back everybody is
quite perplexed at me saying his mind
I haven't revisited the midden so I
suppose I can't claim them to be mine
anymore it's the male on the left since
any chance you can get him he's busy
rubbing he's okay he was busy rubbing
the female with his head and that's what
wildebeest like to do and they
demarcating the area their role in their
own midden and they cover themselves and
dung and then when they've got females
they'll rub themselves on the side of
their body to basically say you are mine
you smell like me now so you belong to
me suppose that's what's going through
their mind he's about to come into
picture there is on the left there's a
fair bit bigger than the females also a
little bit darker the brindle canoe
and we're seeing them every day with
this heard it come down to we're tell a
watering hole have a drink and then
slowly move back to the open areas of
quarantine with the belly full of grass
so as to spend a few hours ruminating
and who knows maybe some lions will be
attracted there tonight and it's about
time isn't it it's been a couple weeks
let's have been here six months you've
had the Inca Houma pride a number of
times on quarantine with make making
kills okay well we are we have got our
infrared light on sins of the magician
has managed to tension on the top sir
we're going to do another another magic
trick for you oh yeah since you can't
too far there are your innocence okay
five oh three two one there we go I like
that I like these magic tricks we're
able to do okay let's look at the Valda
beast again shall we see how they move
in a very good line and there's some of
the imagery we saw from the Mara you see
they've all the bits moving in this long
line as they they graze and they're
pretty much munch everything in their
way all the short grass that wallet
munch all the stuff right at the bottom
the very fresh sort of green shoots that
are coming through and obviously by
moving in a line it's almost like the
way dolphins hunts you know they kind of
don't miss anything as they go and then
cover the entire surface and obviously
move in different lines from time to
time to obviously cover the entire
ground area here feeding on all the new
shoots that are coming forward and you
can see how they busy pluck it most
ruminants that I know if don't have
teeth on the top of the palate
they've just got a lower lower jaw of
teeth as the incisors and then the top
is basically just a plate worth or all
the pellet itself and what they do is
you can see how they grip the grass and
just like
with with the neck just sort of leverage
it up and into the mouth that goes there
won't be too much chewing at the moment
just one or two munches and down the
throat and then later once they find a
suitable place to sit down they could
reach ooh that by regurgitating it again
and maximizing the benefits so it's one
of the bonuses of being a ruminant as
you can have these sort of you can have
these sort of long or these short
periods of feeding followed by sort of
longer periods of rest were you sitting
and ruminating and catching up on a bit
of rest as well as obviously increasing
the digestive 'ti of the food that
you've taken it okay well it seems as if
James is back out and ready to entertain
you with some more antics let's go and
have a look well I'm not fair many
antics will have chivonne this vehicle
but er what we're going to do for the
last few minutes of the drive is head
down towards where ting Ghana was this
morning and hopes that perhaps he's come
across this way it'll be very exciting
indeed we have the fear thermal camera
on it's looking at the road at the
moment and just to let you know what it
is it's a thermal camera which means
what it does is pick up any heat
signature so there are hot bodies off
the road then we'll see those or on the
road
where our eyes are unable to see and
sometimes even the spotlight is unable
to see but mostly if we see something we
can then turn all the lights off and we
don't need at any stage to blind the
animals with bright lights and so our
infrared is very good at doing that and
so is this thermal we've used it last
year and the Mara quite extensively but
it's our first go with this and of
course the thermal drone
in the mornings and we must of course
remind you that we are using the thermal
I in the sky tomorrow morning from 5:30
that's when the drive will begin and
we'll be going 5:30 to 8:30 so an hours
change in the normal drive time which I
imagine will suit most everyone
especially those of you in the u.s. like
to watch you'll summit an hour winter
time when it really is fairly
inconvenient time for a lot of you to
watch for the whole Drive
there is a scrub hell I'm going to keep
going I'm not gonna stop this crud half
and I've quite like to see if we can get
down to see the lip all right now I've
had a message from Emma that sounded
like this indycar chameleon someone died
on guitar I don't know what any of that
means and try to gain Emma
right Pokemon guy would like to see a
chameleon with the thermal on I would be
very interesting to see a chameleon with
the thermal I don't know
we'd see a heat signature because of
course there are reptiles but we'd be
able to tell roughly from the
temperature on the FLIR camera what the
temperature of the chameleons body was
to be very interesting indeed so we'll
certainly try and do that but first
we'll see if we can pick up Tinga
nononononono it was just south of the
boundary this morning threatening to
come north he did come north and then
some warthogs ran south road and he
decided to follow them and I don't think
he caught wounded then he settled in for
lungs in a south
this monitor is gone mad I'm gonna turn
losing me hello just putting on my
jackets here that link very well Emma no
if we go down the road we go
you have two spotlights out
there it is infrared is on working
who knows what we might materialize out
at this time of night we're running down
twin dams right straight away from we
attend a watching hall there's always
interesting creatures moving around so
keeping our eyes peeled
should we go right to the next phone
sensor or maybe we just keep going and
it's go check out chiller pan chenna pan
is drying up quite a lot it was holding
a lot of water for some time and now
it's really really still starting to
turn into a bit of a mud wallow
hello Pascal you want to know what plant
smells like potato and the temperature
drops well very easy to remember because
it is called potato Bush so I'll try and
find you one James is the the experts of
finding potato Bush though maybe we
should ask him I know he loves finding
potato Bush don't you James
since there's just fixing my collar
there I was put my okay apologize for
any technical issues that might be
coming from James's vehicle ago since we
got a a de coeur over there we're gonna
turn off the lights and have a look at
him in the infrared if he's still there
yeah he is just towards the left of the
screen
they are quite relaxed at night what the
infrared because they think we can't see
them they're very slow-moving stealthy
animals like the Stan Bock and you can
see when he puts his feet down the steps
exactly where his previous who who was
to make for very silent movement
listening as they go Tandy's favorite
meal
disappears into the thickets as they do
so that is to the drainage line IRA
spoke earlier about how lipids like
these drainage lines because animals
like day care like to frequent them
being quite a mixed feeder they'll be
moving food they're doing their thing
okay so I don't know where exactly 10
Ghana was left this morning do you know
I was on walk I didn't get the update
sense did you get an update not really
no James was with him I think he must
have crossed he was towards the boundary
in the South covered quite a lot of
distance in the night what is he up to
the old Juke
hello David do you want to know what
chameleons going the one so while
they're still around they might find you
one
they're just a little bit more a little
harder to see I suppose because the
leaves are disappearing so they have to
sort of select certain trees to be on
and trees that insects are gonna
frequent but yeah we don't seem to find
as many in that in the winter as we do
in the summer months which I don't quite
know the reason for that they are round
though they don't go anywhere
some of the females models sometimes
they kill themselves when they lay eggs
the females it's quite an exert of
process going onto the ground
digging a hole laying up to 50 eggs and
then sometimes the exertion is just too
much and they might die and that's one
of the reasons what's wrong sense okay
one of the reasons why it's it's it's
also locally with the shunga and people
quite a no-go to touch a chameleon
because they think that if you touch one
it gives rise it gives rise to a whole
lot more first of all they think you'd
be touched when it's going to kill it
and then a whole lot more gonna come out
and that comes basically from the story
that someone must have been walking
along one there and found a dead
chameleon on the ground and because the
chameleons bury their eggs on the ground
50 odd youngsters were crawling out of
the ground underneath is dead chameleon
so then the story went that don't touch
them because not only will it die but
there will be 50 more so that's one of
those stories that probably gets passed
down and down and down and then it
becomes one of those things and sins
will do touch a chameleon say since I
won't is is Zulu and he won't touch a
chameleon so I'm possibly might be quite
a widespread belief in southern Africa
you know such things you told by your
grandfather you know don't do that and
you listen to you listen to your
grandparents sense yeah very much very
very much
okay well it seems as if James has
sorted out some technical difficulties
let's go and have a look what's going on
me well for now we've managed to sort
them out let's hope it stays like that
yes some major technical difficulties
but of course this is why these daily
safaris are so very important without
them these technical difficulties would
arise during example television and then
that would be a complete disaster
Buffalo dung going down this road
Oh even a loose picture lose put how's
the picture still absolutely fine and
any sense to me at all anyway
yeah this goes to Steve
okay well we've found a scrub here I'm
not sure what's going on with James's
vehicle some obviously as we advanced
the technology fingers are always going
to go wrong there we go there's a scrub
it once again with the iolite he is
coming out he's already eaten his poo
from last night
now it's time to munch on a little bit
of forb before bore to his cheeks very
cute cheeks tea thought we believed
always growing as their munching
annoying mmm he could be turned a food
or Columba the lumber seems to like a
little bit of scrub here yeah while
we're coming up in China pan as we
suggested before and who knows what
could be coming down to have themselves
a a very muddy drink
could be anything could be nothing as
well there's there something there since
there is the the remains of chillip an
have a little look at it shall we can
you see it in the darkness there's we
should call it to chill a mud
Chella means to to to give or to take I
think to give a sense Taylor
chill as to to pass on if I'm not
mistaken
Jayla well it is I've been passing on
for some time and it is almost right but
it has been a remarkable amount of
activity at that pan since I've been
here plenty of stuff going on you might
have just heard the noise of a over
water thick knee or spotted thick knee
in the background you might also have
heard that branch that I just smashed or
you didn't that's fantastic ok lights
are on ok so last minute Leppard here we
go
everyone's excited no doubt last-minute
lipid this afternoon it was an Impala
chilling will leave the impart or alone
he's just busy doing what I spoke about
with the Valle de beast having a little
bit of a sit down in a room ination
discussing his thoughts
so we're right in the heart of Jummah
coming from coming from chillip and
coming up towards weavers nest and let's
go back to James for you to say another
few words let's hope this one lasts I'm
very sorry about this what I'll do is
just pull on to the tree house down wall
here I think the more static we are the
better it will work and then we can have
a look at least vaguely with the thermal
camera and see what's here at the
waterhole alright let's train that bad
boy on the water and see what we get no
it's losing it still got picture there
we go good still a picture you can see
the thermal now look with the hot hot
trees of course there's there's no
leopard walking towards us but it's
still a pretty purple pink orange and
yellow
picture and very nice to be listening to
the crickets in the background
now come on let's get something come out
of there
let's keep going round there otherwise
we can look at the other side of the
damn wall you with hot spots there
started dreaming about hot spots
everybody desperate looking for that
looks like it warm done petit perhaps
the Buffalo is close by oh look at that
it is an Egyptian ghouls look at his
reflection
oh that's too gorgeous it's a hot ghouls
as Emma says yes you can see the
feathers insulating it very nicely but
the bare skin on the face in oh dear
we're losing picture I don't know if
we're going to be able to close the show
let's try let me still find good stuff
well we have a few seconds left thank
you very much for joining us let's just
not move the camera fur glisters leave
it right where it is thank you for your
patience tomorrow morning will be Steve
and I again and then tomorrow afternoon
the great return of stiff inventor booth
to the Safari oh we've lost that picture
now oh well see what we can do tomorrow
have a good evening
we'll try and do the same see you
tomorrow morning
[Music]